So let's take a quick look at the
filter playground method where you've been adding your filters.
And here you see I've added the filter for
month equals six which basically says, give me the
conferences in June then I deployed that to
AppSpot. And I went to the API's explorer for
my project, actually out on AppSpot this is not
in local host. Chose my method, my playground method,
executed it and you see I get an error and it's a backend error. So one thing we
can do at this point is to go look at the index viewer in the admin console. To
get there, you go to the console.developers.google.com, you select
your project and then over here you choose cloud
data store and then you choose indexes. You see
the indexes that have already been created. And these are
what we'd expect, we already searched for this ancestor query,
which basically give me all conferences for a user, where the
user was the ancestor of the conference. And then we have
this other one where we search for city topics and name
and if you've never actually deployed your app with this
filter to Appspot. You won't see this filter, but that's okay,
that's fine. Now what I want you to do is to
go back to Eclipse and I want you to look at
the automatically generated index configuration file. So to get to that,
sorry this is a little hard to see but you go into the Target directory. You
drill down into Conference-1.0. Then into Web-inf,
then into app engine generated and you
see data store-indexes-auto. Now exactly what you
see might be different to what I've
got here but it's perfectly fine if it's blank.
It may already have some index configurations in it.
Now what I'm going to do is run Conference
Central on Local Host. Okay my Dev App Server's
now running. So, I'm going to go to the API's
Explorer on Local Host. Make sure you're at, in
the API's Explorer on Local Host not back in
your App on App spot. Again, we drill down,
we got to our filter playground method. I get
a response, I don't actually have any items that match
that query but this doesn't matter at this point.
So now I go back to Eclipse. I'm going to look
at my index configuration file again and you see
that this index configuration entry has been automatically added for
me. I didn't write this, app engine routed when it
run the query on local host. So, I'm searching for
kind Conference, no ancestor. I'm searching for filtering by
city, filtering by month, filtering by topics, filtering by
name. I should not filtering by name, I'm sorting
by name but to all intents and purposes a
sort order is a filter. So now, I'm going to
go run my app again on App Spot. When
you deploy your application to App Spot, the updated
index configuration file will be deployed with it and
App Engine will start to build your new index. Back
in the index viewer page in the admin console for
my app running on App Spot, I see that my
new index is preparing. Now if I actually run this query
again I'll still get an error and I'll keep getting
an error until it's finished preparing. It needs to be
ready to serve before I can run the query. So
to get ready for the query I'm just going to go
ahead and make sure I've got some conferences that will satisfy
the query. So I'm searching for conferences, in London about medical innovations
happening in June. If you made any changes in your query
property you'll need to create a conference that satisfies your query criteria.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, let's go and see how our index is
doing, see if it's built yet. Okay, good, it
has. It's no longer preparing, so it's ready to
serve. So, over here in the API's Explorer for
my app on App Spot, I will run my query again. Execute it. Oh good and it found
the conference I just created. Which matches all the
filters on the query. Good. One thing to mention
is that when you deploy an app that needs a new
index, the request to update the index actually goes into a queue
along with other similar requests, so your index may not get
updated immediately. And that could be why it may take a little
bit longer to prepare than you think if might need to.
It's not because it take a long time to build the index,
although sometimes it can but generally the wait time is just
waiting for your request to get to the top of the queue.
So another thing that you could do instead of running your query on local host
is that you can create your own index
configuration, called datastore/indexes.xml so whatever indexes are defined
in either the datastore/index. Says file that
you created or in the order generated, datastore
dash indexes dash auto. When you deploy your
app to App Spot both those index configuration
files will go up and any indexes defined
in either of those files will be created
and you'll be able to serve queries that
use the filters defined in those index configuration files